[Music]  what were you like in college is you  what were you did you belong any clubs  any societies tell us there was a junior  classical league that was my Latin club  that tells you a lot right you know yeah  I spoke I don't really speak that's a  dead language I studied it for six years  and I'm up a lot like my any Roman  soldiers around here you read Virgil's  the Aeneid in Latin yes ah that's pretty  much the whole course over the six years  put it on by the way I think the back of  my area oh no it's still there  right on my ear see oh okay that's not  the wardrobe malfunction we were rooting  for are you gonna do it's beautiful  that's gorgeous no I wasn't in junior  high you do you do that so we would  entertain ourselves by using Latin in  other ways for instance we translated  all the lyrics to Bon Jovi's mala medic  inna that's bad medicine you and I are  perfect for each other